foreign
[Music]
good morning or afternoon to everyone
and Welcome to our webinar Don't Fear
the robots uh lab automation for high
throughput Discovery Science brought to
you by open transimate research
we're very excited to introduce our
speaker Dr Carlos Miller from North
Carolina State University in Raleigh
North Carolina
Carlos is an associate teaching
professor at the department of
biological sciences and he teaches in
the biotechnology program there uh he's
really passionate about teaching with
technology and including lab Automation
and molecular biology education
and he's made it his mission to
integrate it into courses and
undergraduate research experiences
he also has an NSF funded project to
create a network of Educators to build
case studies teaching students about
high throughput approaches to drug
screening microscopy sequencing and
other high throughput applications
um so we're really excited to hear him
talk about his work in this area today
and I'm also here with Gregory Lee from
zymo research Gregory is the automation
manager at zymo and his team played a
very Hands-On role helping Carlos and
and other uh and others develop
automation workflows
and finally I'm Fran Slater I'm a senior
director of strategic marketing at
opentrons and I'm really happy to be
able to host this webinar and hear more
from Carlos
thank you so much for the kind
invitation and both of you open trons
and zymo have been really helpful in
getting us up and running and sharing
um a little bit about Automation and my
passion for teaching this in both the
undergraduate and graduate lab
so I'll speak a little bit about using
the uh use
of course the phone rings
okay
sorry about that
so I am happy to be here and I love
learning about Automation and teaching
about it and
today I'll speak about using the ot2 to
teach High throughput Discovery so I
really tried to emphasize in our
biotechnology classes that I throughput
Discovery is something that can and
should occur in undergraduate and
graduate molecular biotechnology
education and we can do that by
exploring the design for experiments
that require automation and this is all
based on the experience of teaching this
class bit for biotechnology
479 579
with the ot2 for several years now
so a little bit about this my my
catchphrase for several years has been
Don't Fear the robot and that's because
I think lab automation should be part of
molecular biology training and to do
that we need both
the instruments as well as the awareness
of how automation helps high throughput
Discovery Science and I Define that as
using both instrumentation as well as
experimental design to propel advances
in generation of new knowledge about
active compounds about cell phenotypes
for example and learning and we can
learn a lot from how we teach automation
to students and I want to share a little
bit about that
so in 2015 I was a biotechnology at
teaching postdoctoral scholar here at NC
State we are fortunate to have a program
where we can
cultivate the research app
education that a postdoctoral research
Scholars bring and provide the
opportunity to design new classes so in
my case I came and was able to work in
the biotechnology program to design a
class on metagenomics so going from a
swab in our case we swapped kitchen
sinks to learning about what microbes
are there using sequencing Technologies
have it's a three-year postdoctoral
Fellowship how you learn about course
design you learn about classroom
management you teach and design a
lab-based course
and I was finishing up that experience
and had the opportunity to apply for a
teaching faculty position in the same
biotechnology program and I pitched the
idea of Designing a class called high
throughput discovery
and our tagline
and goal was to engage students in lab
and computer-based activities that
featured Automation and high throughput
Discovery Science and to do this
Stephanie Chen Dr Stephanie Chen also
here in the biotechnology program and I
designed the course after surveying both
faculty here at NC State researchers in
the Research Triangle Park have down the
street
researchers from Duke University UNC
Chapel Hill
collaborators from Southern Research
Institute in Alabama and elsewhere and
automation experts and we asked them the
question if you were to develop a high
throughput Discovery class what would
you need
and now what would you focus on
and this helped us design a course and
write module and course objectives so we
have a set of six or seven course
objectives that we wanted all
participants and I should mention that
this is a half semester lab-based course
for undergraduate and graduate students
from several different majors and
programs throughout our campus
and we decide several modules
seven modules each addressing different
questions so for example the first
module is what this High throughput
Discovery and module two is what makes a
good screen where we talk about
reproducibility Z factors and
calculations
we were able to purchase an app motion
EP 5075 and two open trons ot2
instruments thanks to internal grants
and funding and this got us up and
running and we were able to Pilot
experiments in the lab with students and
a fantastic graduate student Jamie
nosbech
and
the class took off
I was hired as teaching faculty in 2015
after proposing that course
Dr Stephanie Channel and I designed the
course with help from Jamie we launched
it and launched at the labs in the
spring of 2016 we had at that time just
the EP motion
and we limited the class to 12 students
so that we could work in groups of four
and four students would work in front of
the instrument and eight other students
would work on some what we called uh
quad quizzes so some of the math behind
some of the screening procedures we
really refined the labs in 2016 and 2017
2018 we were tying into some campus-wide
challenges because we realized High
throughput Discovery required compound
libraries so at the National Cancer
Institute shared ah
a couple of compounds libraries not huge
ones but
big enough that we were able to do some
high throughput screening with students
as part of the class we partnered with
some chemists down the street uh Josh
Pierce and his lab to screen some
potential antimicrobial compounds
we used my pet micro delfti acid of
orange as a case study and we gave
students before Kobe in 2018 we did a
campus-wide challenge where we gave a
first-year environmental science student
and staff and faculty and Friends of the
library we gave them swab kits and we
said where do you think this microbe
that's able to precipitate Liquid Gold
to Solid Gold nanoparticles where does
Delta see the warrants live on our
campus and we made little stickers and
we shared them with the campus and got
swab kits and had had
participants sent samples in
and we screened them as part of the
class for the presence of this microbe
using the using at that time
real-time PCR
in 2018 we applied for internal funding
and we I had the opportunity to write a
science technology engineering and math
internal Proposal with my partner at Dr
Claire Gordy in genetics and we pitched
the idea Don't Fear the robot use
automation use ot2s
in both the biotechnology and the
genetics labs
and we were able to purchase two
instruments two ot2s with all of the
modules at that time and use them in the
class so now we have the opportunity to
really engage all students groups of
four uh two groups of four were working
on the ot2s one was working on
dep motion and we rotated the groups and
during our five and a half hour Labs so
everyone had a chance to really work
with the instruments and learn how to
program dumb how to app some of the
challenges when it comes to piping
certain liquids and we had a fantastic
time with that class that we offered
Every Spring and uh one fall
in 2017 and then in 2020 in the spring
of 2020 in the middle of our half
semester course after the first
in-person Lab at the massive shutdown
that came about with the pandemic and we
were forced to go online
and I found myself strapping a GoPro
camera that I have up there to a liquid
Handler and to the ot2 and trying to
make videos and I stopped and asked
myself is this gonna work what are we
what are you doing Carlos how are you
going to teach a course based on
instrumentation online
I'm in 2020 in the spring of 2020 we
switched to online and we developed a
completely online asynchronous high
throughput Discovery course I want to
talk to you about and this was with lots
of help from open trads and zymo
and today we're back to in-person Labs
but we still are using several of those
components from the online experience
so what did we do with ot2s we designed
open trons challenge activities
these were group activities in groups of
four undergraduate and graduate students
from different majors and programs with
the goal of familiar Rising Learners
with the software and open trans
operation
to do this these students work together
to successfully complete a procedure
using vot2
the teams began with food coloring and
just calibrating the instrument making
ot to open trons logos
at doing patterns with food coloring a
96 and then 384 well plates
and every week
we increase the level of complexity
which included downloading scripts from
the opentrons site and using scripts
with different plates and Tube formats
telling students
well eight six and h12 have candidate
compounds
cherry pick those and do dilutions do
those response curves
and at that time we were trying a couple
of
zymo app 96 well played DNA extraction
and RNA extraction kits as part of this
class and tying in to that metagenomics
class that I
have been teaching since 2013.
so students progressively learned
confidence
or gained confidence with this
instrument and the software and
calibrating it and then by the end of a
couple of weeks they were able to use
the protocol designer from opentrons to
create their own Scripts
and thanks to Jonathan lab's help from
zymo and sharing graciously sharing how
they approach automation of kids after
sharing some of the plate layouts and
some of the reagents and racks how they
set them up we share that information
with students and said here's a
biological question
can you address that biological question
with this zymobiomics kit or this direct
Sol RNA kit and the open trons
so this is an example of a software
challenge software challenge one you'll
notice that it's
um in an electronic lab notebook we use
students work in groups but they each
have to individually
pleat the challenge in terms of the
write-up and the reflection we have some
reflective questions the first challenge
really tells them
step by step what's happening set up the
deck of the open trons with this you are
going to do
this with food coloring and create this
pattern
and the goal here was
um
challenges that encourage students to
explore the ot2 familiarize themselves
with calibration uh with running scripts
with some of the troubleshooting yep
with adding tips the different
consequences of not having the right
volumes or not uh not thinking about the
placement of things and it was it's
stress free it was
food coloring add lots of reusable
plates and the groups worked on it and
then after that and now we would rotate
to the next station and if the groups
were encouraged to work together and
share share
and for example group one encounter this
issue we fixed it this way what will
group two do
and then by the time we get to software
challenge four in week four of this
eight week course you'll note that
the software challenges become
a little less prescriptive it's
the goal is stated but then we just say
maybe it was because Carlos was lazy
maybe we just say visit the protocol
page here download the script and now
edit the script
to do this or to do this number of
samples instead
and the goal here was to increase the
level of difficulty promote Independence
and allow students to explore some of
the higher complexities complexity tasks
that automation can enable us to do
so by increasing Independence and
providing students practice and allowing
that time for them to explore and
exchange ideas with peers
troubleshooting became part of the
process we laughed when liquids and tips
fell
we shared strategies with peers and the
deliverable was always as part of those
electronic lab notebook entries we
always had a deliverable that was an
image an image of
hopefully success maybe a plate with
food coloring or maybe a plate with
bacterial cultures
but even if it wasn't successful we
encourage students to take pictures of
workarounds as there were some really
fantastic workarounds
and for example in this screenshot on
the right we have an open trans protocol
and we encourage students to complete
this script with minor modifications and
share their successes
so when it came time to combining the
ot2 with zyma research kits we use the
ximobiomics and Mac B96 kits to engage
students in the design of unique
experiments and this included scripts
and clever solutions to address novel
biological questions so again in groups
with the help of a fantastic
postdoctoral scholar whose expertise is
in a plant genomics Dr Carly shogran
nanai designed the online version of
this course
so again interdisciplinary groups we
were lucky to have two or three
instructors so two that postdoctoral
scholar myself and The Graduate ta and
we each took on the task of being a
coach for a group of four or five
students and what we decided was to do a
job Journal of visualized
experimentation style manuscript based
on the design of an experiment using the
ot2 and one of the kits so we told
students and throughout the online
course which was completely asynchronous
with some in-person in
in sync or synchronous Zoom open hours
for students to talk to each other and
talk to us
throughout the online course we offered
students at articles that used
Automation and these are articles from
the journal jove and these include if
you haven't seen them they include
videos with the researchers walking
through a procedure and it allowed us to
bring instrumentation we don't
necessarily have access to so new
technologies new liquid handlers as well
as bring
liquid handling and robots really great
science
online
so students watch the drove videos
throughout the semester we had one every
other week and then their task was to
address a biological question that the
instructors came up with
using one of the kits xymobiomics or
macbead 96 for DNA or RNA we told them
about the protocol designer and we
helped coach groups of students to
design and develop and write a
manuscript that they had to Def
um submit at the end of the semester
so
this allowed us to really have fun with
the process of Automation and Leverage
The protocol designer
as well as zymo kits
I have expertise from zymo from
designmo automation team to have
students design really novel
applications to for example screen
bacterial isolates after extracting DNA
as setting up digital PCR to real-time
PCR extracting RNA in two different
conditions for bacteria treated with
heavy metals people got really creative
and produced detailed scripts as well as
articles with the steps and the reagents
and this was also thanks to the
availability of the open trans protocol
designer and these kits from zymo
that I'm going to transition over to how
Simo allowed us to do this
thank you Carlos uh actually I'm I
thought I'm excited I wonder if I can be
participating in your class and maybe
speak to your students I always speak to
you and you're lovely but I'm excited
the awesome meal to speak to your
students
but uh maybe I can take a moment and uh
I can speak to you all about uh well we
mentioned zymo research uh so so what is
I'm a research I'm a research just as a
a sort of General introduction we're a
biotech company
um we were known for specializing in uh
DNA RNA extraction
um but uh
we've also gone into the fields of
microbiomics epigenetics as Carlos had
mentioned we
were very much in this field of
microbiomics and metagenomics
so our real goal is to be able to
provide tools
for researchers
um
numerous number of fields right whether
it be basic research and Discovery or
application research you know clinical
Diagnostics even down to personalized
medicine applications
but fundamentally we're in a vision
company and uh
we simply use
biochemistry is our Tool uh to find
applications
and so we've expanded that to become not
only knowing sort of the the research
and the ability uh to to apply these
tools uh but we also realized uh well if
we're going to sort of get these tools
out to researchers we need to get them
out in the best way so we developed even
as a kind of True Manufacturing company
which is not only we're designing and
Manufacturing the biochemicals utilized
for our assays but even developing into
uh you know disposables and and full
kits
and kids not just for extraction but
even down through the real-time PCR or
Library generation
well as part of the expansion and part
of that need we realized
um
we need to help people get into
automation
um
not specific to automation but really A
methodology for high throughput
processing
so we just usually just refer that to
automation uh in a way what Carlos was
speaking about uh
we saw the very definite need
um for our field the biotech field
to expand in this direction
um
this is a fortnightly independent so uh
maybe like any good scientist we see
that there are two independent
experiments that led to the same
conclusion
um
but the I guess benefit to Carlos is
that he gets to teach his class and uh
for us from our end we have to
um work with customers where they're at
and
I would never say there is a lack of
understanding
but there's oftentimes a lack of
familiarity
so for us our aim as part of the Zama
research automation team is really to
create simple user-friendly
something that's readily accessible uh
for customers to easily carry out their
experimentation uh
on an instrument
in this case you know for for college
Carlos and his class they need them they
essentially started working with uh open
trans ot2s
so where do we start
um how is our process uh work
well one we have the benefit of having
kind of very robust and flexible
biochemistry or chemistry
um we know our kids very well and in
fact
my entire team although yeah we're
composed of Engineers and uh scientists
of multiple backgrounds we
we specialize in the vote a lot of time
understanding uh our particular
chemistry in kids
and that helps right because then we
know uh what kind of shortcuts we can
take or how we can modify our protocols
uh to get the most uh robust application
on a high throughput system
very basically made me to step back is
whenever we look at a project we always
Define it in three major steps one is
the scripting which is the actual
programming so I think you know Carlos
touched on that very well uh you know
getting his his his
these students used to the program uh
getting used to
um the ot2's protocol designer and
that's essentially what we we also do we
need to spend a lot of time planning and
scripting and making sure that
um
what we what we desire for the open
trons ot2 to do we've planned that very
well through our scripting process
the next step on that is implementation
so that's again what Carlos is doing
with this class he's getting them
working with the actual instrument uh
when you tell an instrument to pipette a
certain amount of liquid does it do it
and does it do it from the right trough
into the right well
so uh that's that's just part of the
process
and um for us we go through one more
step
um
it can kind of be said that Carlos also
does that with his group in terms of
experiments but because we uh
are are defining an assay kit we go
through a process called verification or
validation
we utilize the term verification because
verification means that we have
particular metrics that we want to hit
um from our kit on the ot2 system but it
doesn't necessarily validate for a
particular experiment so that's really
the only difference between the two
terminologies
so
um
what does this all mean after we've done
script gang after we've done
implementation after we've done
verification how does this
help a customer
well even though we could basically hand
over a script
um and hand over an assay kit
we realized that is still a very
intimidating process
um so we we we went back
and we realized there's a need a want
and a nice to have for custom
ERS yes the customer needs a script yes
the customer needs a kit
um and they want that make sure that
that script and kit work on a particular
machine
we realize it's also very nice to have a
sort of designed out
um
protocol and they're designed out
presentation to give to customers I
think that's uh you know what Carlos was
alluding to is that when we provide a
lot of our support we try to not only
help customers Surf and students
understand what they're about to do
but have a sense of familiarity have a
sense of I can do this I can achieve
this
you know we like to have
things presented in a way that makes
makes everyone feel that science is
accessible
and that the high throughput field is
accessible which is why we're
more than happy to be working with uh
Carlos's group as well as the open trial
scene because we have the same goal of
accessibility
Making Science accessible to everyone
and so with this accessibility look like
well you always Define it as
capability
capacity and consistency this is no
different than whether you're working
with
High throughput applications
or really when you're when you're just
doing uh signs on a bench
but we want to make sure that we Grant
customers capability
on their instruments
by providing all the the resources
making sure they have the capacity
meaning that
um if they have a large number of
samples to to process what does that
look like maybe even Beyond just having
one ot2 maybe they need to have a few
ot2s set up
and consistency
meaning that whether day in day out
you're still getting the same results
you're still getting the same robust uh
uh
values and uh
things that you've seen day to day and
between user to user
so uh
a lot of this
isn't just dependent upon the
chemistries that we produce it's not
just dependent upon the protocols we
produce it's very dependent upon
the hardware of the machines and so
um May I turn it over to Fran and she
can go over this this robust system of
of the open trons ot2
great thanks Greg and um thanks also
Carlos for the uh great presentation it
was fantastic to hear not only your
enthusiasm but obviously the the
enthusiasm of your students really
really came through
um so yeah I uh we'll just start off
explaining a little bit about open
trends for people who maybe haven't
heard heard about us so we we make
robots for biologists to put it very
simply
um uh not just robots but you know the
robotics the software and the community
tools
um for life scientists uh and as um
Carlos has already mentioned uh our
Flagship robot is the ot2 which is an
accessible benchtop liquid Handler
um that's really built for life
scientists and especially molecular
biology
and uh this is what the ot2 looks like
it fits on half a half a lap bench
um it's uh compared to normal uh lab
Automation and liquid handling
Technologies it's incredibly affordable
so
um Gregory just mentioned accessibility
and and he mentioned that that's what
we're all about and that's absolutely
true right one of the
um one of the things that prevent people
from uh
um getting into lab automation is the is
the high cost up front High upfront cost
um and then also as Carlos mentioned the
fear right so that's something that I
think we're all very committed to is is
really opening up the possibility of uh
lab automation to uh a broader audience
so the ot2s uh has high performance
comparable to robots that are much more
expensive to it than it
um it's also flexible I'll show you a
little bit about the I'll show you on
another slide a little bit about the
modularity of of the the platform and
it's open so our software is open source
uh and um it's uh consumable and reagent
agnostic so you can use
um any reagents in any laptop on there
um it's also powerful so
um Carlos mentioned uh the protocol
designer which I'll show you in a second
but we also have a python API so for
complete control you can really script
um
uh the robot to do anything you want so
you can either use the protocol designer
which is a GUI or or there is a
transcripting capabilities
and it's supported right so you know we
have a team of field application
scientists and support uh folks and
applications Engineers who are there to
really help people get up and running
and then of course we also partner with
um zymo and and Gregory and and teams
like that to uh help
um customers get up and running with
particular reagents on particular robots
so I'll just show you a little bit
um oh sorry this is uh uh you know what
what do people use the ot2 for well a
lot um and there's a really wide range
of applications
um that you can use the ot2 for but the
applications that Carlos has been
talking about so really molecular
biology and uh microbiomics and um NGS
but you know those are the those are the
really
um popular applications so uh there's a
list of applications that are most are
most frequently used for the ot2 and
really genomics and released
applications are are a kind of sweet
spot
uh I mentioned the modularity of the
system and this is just a a cute graphic
that shows that shows this in real time
so there are um what we call Deck
positions on the robot so there are 11
places that you can put things on the
robot and those uh can be Hardware
modules like a thermocycler they can
there can be tips and labware like a 961
plate anything that has an SBS a
standard SPS footprint can fit on the
deck and you can move those things
around depending on uh your application
and your workflow in the top right hand
corner the only thing that isn't moving
is the is the waste and so that's where
the tips get
um uh get ejected
um as I mentioned it's those deck
positions are for SPS format
um consumables and hardware and so on
uh and all of this everything can be
removed as well so
um all of that uh all of the consumables
but also the hardware such as
thermocyclists or magnetic modules they
can all be removed and moved around
and then pipettes we have a variety of
pipettes that could be put onto the
Gantry it can hold up to two pipettes at
the same time and you can choose the
pets that you want based on your
application so we have single Channel
options and eight channel options in a
variety of volumes and they're sort of
all interchangeable with each other
and so we also have a variety of
Hardware modules I'm just showing the
magnetic module here because uh it's one
that is commonly really commonly used
for magnetic bead-based applications
such as
um zymos microbiomics kit and others so
it's uh it has um it's difficult to see
here but it has an array of magnets that
kind of pop up in between the the Wells
on a 96 well or uh plate and engage and
attract the magnetic beads and then when
it comes to when it when is appropriate
time that the magnets kind of disengage
and so on it's a it's a it's a cool
design for
um doing magnetic bead based uh
extractions and similar work
and
finally I just wanted to show a little
bit about protocol designer so this is
the GUI that the Carlos's group use in
their experiments
um uh and it's a it's a code free GUI
software that helps you to build
protocols
um I will show a quick demonstration
video of it in a sec so you can but
generally it's it's pretty intuitive you
know it's all Visual and so on and you
can lay the deck out how you want select
hardware and liquids and then you can
program
uh the pipettes to transfer you know the
right uh the right liquid from the right
well at right trough to the right well
at the right time
and so here's a quick
um 30 second video to show what that
looks like
okay
um
that's about it
um I just wanted to say thank you to
Carlos especially and also Gregory for
joining us for this webinar and for
giving such an interesting presentation
um and also I'd like to thank all of um
the students that have gone through cast
this course
um and have also obviously contributed
to to this work in such an important way
so thank you so much everybody and um
now we'll open it up for questions
okay
um so welcome to the Q a session
everyone
um we have five or six questions already
uh the people have entered into into the
Q a box but if anyone has uh other
questions we have plenty of time to
address them so just uh type them into
the bottom left-hand corner and we'll
get to those questions as well
uh so
um I'll pick a I'll pick a random one to
start on
um so Carlos start with you what has
been your students feedback regarding uh
the courses that you've been talking
about
I I think the
this is a tough question that depends if
we have undergraduate and graduate
students
some graduate students are now go back
to their labs and ask for example I need
uh do we have access to someone on the
floor with the automation no can we get
an open trans can we look into
um automating this process because we do
it routinely as some
undergrads uh go out and get jobs in
biotech and then come back and say guess
what I've been using this or that
instrument and I've been doing this so
that's really great
we've also have the the perspective of
some students loving the challenge of
um the scripting and thinking about the
steps
um so we've had a couple of people
mentioned oh I love the challenge and
now I'm learning more about python
they like the graphical user interface
but they found that it was more powerful
to be able to Define things exactly how
they want it
yeah very cool and python is becoming
like a really you know really like a
really dominant coding language so I
think everyone should be learning python
at some point in that how to graduate
education
um
okay let's jump to the next question and
maybe I'll
um it's more of a technical question
about the zymo kit so I'll put this one
to Greg uh what's the maximum throughput
for DNA or RNA extraction using xymo
kits on the ot2
[Music]
yeah uh that's a great question uh
because it talks about basic throughput
um
on the ot2
we we basically design it so all of our
kits will be our walk away at uh at
least 24 samples some of them can do 48
and walk away but primarily we just say
generally right
um it's going to be 24 samples
um
but that can always change depending on
what everyone wants to do or manipulate
in terms of the chemistry
um but I would also say that ot2 is
certainly capable of doing 96 samples at
a time uh just the story limitation is
you know you kind of run out of tips so
you need to add more tips or this or
that so the capability of the machine uh
an instrument is there uh you know for
typically where people want to process
about 96 samples
um but if you kind of want to just press
a button and just just let the machine
do its thing uh it's typically minimum
24.
excellent
thanks Greg
um one again for you Carlos so um
uh you have an NSF funded Grant to sort
of build a network of Educators uh uh
sort of interested in some of the
aspects that you were talking about in
terms of building courses and curriculum
um how can how can people join that
Network
um to collaborate on that oh that's
that's
really good because we have we have
ongoing efforts to try to expand the
network and and it's going to be hits
version two and I'll put um
the website is go.ncsu
for North Carolina State university.edu
forward slash
hits
so Sabrina Robertson came up with a
really awesome acronym and that takes
you to a Cube's page that's q u
e e s so quantitative undergraduate
biology education system and that's
where we have a community of people
developing resources case studies at to
bring height throughput into a variety
of classes and for me it's it's fun to
play with high throughput is automation
or sequencing but there are several
other ways of doing High throughput
science
excellent
thanks so much because
um uh this is more of a general question
I think it would be good if if everyone
sort of answered from their perspective
sort of in turn
um but what what's my first step if my
lab wants to implement automation so
Carlos I'll start with you as someone
who has implemented automation
oh
and this is gonna sound silly but ah
do it in class I'm a big fan of flow
charts and diagrams and just go find a
whiteboard or find paper draw out the
main steps
and of the procedure and think about
what um
can this be automated and in a way that
will save you time and can be used over
and over and then if you have access to
a liquid Handler now that you have your
main steps and your thinking in terms of
where can I put this volume of liquid
that I have to distribute into this
number of vessels
uh then bring out the food coloring
that's when you use food coloring and
ethanol when you have
ethanol stuff or a reagent with ethanol
or glycerol and a test at first with
food coloring and for us in a teaching
setting that's really great we we often
take a protocol
download it from zymo or or download the
protocol from kyogen and say okay we
want to automate this
um
these are the main steps after you drew
them out let's let's load up the liquid
Handler and do it with food coloring
yeah food coloring is like that's such a
top tip
glad you mentioned that
um Greg what's your perspective on that
implementing automation
yeah
um I guess from um
automations kind of Specialist or
technical help
um
like Carla said drawing up the flow
charts actually really important because
I I think oftentimes when we when we go
into this idea of like automation we
immediately think okay what's the
instrument I need and
um which is fair it's a fair thought
right because that's that's the biggest
investment typically it but I would say
you know chart out the whole process
that you're trying to achieve
and figure out where your bottlenecks
are
right because if you're really there's
one thing to say like I want to do
automation
um
but I guess just from our background
like well
you know wanting is great and then
that's where you can get into
experimentation and and and and just
basically say like okay well at least
here's my flow chart and here's what I
can do with the liquid Handler
um
but from the aspect of well what is the
need that the automation is going to
meet well that's where these flow charts
and understanding where your bottlenecks
are are going to help you and can the
liquid help you know handler do that for
you
um you know it's it's great that we can
you know place a zymo kit onto an open
trons ot2
but if that really isn't your bottleneck
right
um you know if you're only doing let's
say like
two samples a week
maybe maybe putting it onto you know an
open trons robot you know to meet a need
isn't necessarily there
um so uh yeah I I always
recommend uh you know from customers or
those that come and ask us is you know
what what is the need that the robot
needs to meet for your lab or for your
your business and um
you know then you know how to ask the
right questions right ask the right
questions from the instrument vendor you
know from open trons from zymo
um and uh I would also say it it also
helps address not just
sort of what hit I need to place onto
the onto the instrument but
it opens up what the capabilities
instrument can do like even from sample
handling like distribution of the sample
into a plate
um yeah certainly you know doing
extractions using a zymo kit but even
your library prep uh cherry picking all
those sort of things can be done be
opened up uh by using the instrument
so I'm going to turn it over to you
friend like what's yours
um yeah I think definitely like to
analyze those bottlenecks and start
small like all you know almost all
automation is somehow modular right so
you can you don't have to go for a
six-figure setup you know just get
started you know wouldn't that be great
if everyone had that budget to play with
but you know you can you can do it step
by step
um I also think that
um
looking for lots of help is really
important so Greg mentioned you know
that
um
you know open trans and all automation
vendors should be able to give you a
significant amount of help in terms of
analyzing what it is that you want to
automate it and giving you advice about
how to do that
um and whether you should do it or you
know what what the pros and cons are
timing studies all these things to
really give you some some information
about what that automated solution would
look like
and I think also like from the community
so open Trends is very we're very big
into
um
uh uh
um incoming into Community sort of an
engagement and involvement and that's
true for people that want to start
automating as well there are lots of
forums out there and lots of you know
people who are already automating what
you want to automate and so then you
know I think that's really interesting
really important to connect with those
people and and get their perspective on
how to do it when to do it and so on
okay excellent
um
okay so we have a couple of ot2 specific
questions which I could probably answer
so the first one is what level of
programming do I need to know to operate
an ot2 so
um a little or a lot I think is uh sort
of it's a sort of answer there and I
will also get cars from great to win
knowing that they obviously have worked
extensively with an OG too but um
fundamentally we offer we have a four
different ways
um to kind of get your protocol done so
the most uh uh introductory way is to
use our protocol designer GUI which
Carlos mentioned using and which I
showed a little bit of a of a short demo
in the in the talk
um it's you know it's GUI based it's
very uh sort of friendly to use and it's
a good way of kind of beginning to kind
of play around with the robot and on the
opposite side of that we do have python
API so you can if you are familiar with
python and if you really want to get you
know
um a very sophisticated level of control
over the ot2 you can write your
protocols in Python
um and that enables you to do almost
Limitless uh things with the ot2 right
you can really
um create very bespoke protocols that
way
um we also offer two other things as
well so we have a protocol Library where
you can find protocols that other people
have written either
open trons protocols that our science
team has written or protocols submitted
from the community so they might not
exactly kind of do what you want you
know that it's you know obviously a lot
of people have specific needs but
they're a good base they're a good
starting point now people find them good
to to review as a starting point for a
particular
application and then finally we have an
FAS team field application scientists
who will write protocols for you that's
a paid service so
uh you know obviously it depends on on
how you want to do it and what your
budget is but we provide kind of
consultation and scripting for you
um but I'll ask
um maybe Carlos and Greg to weigh in on
on programming the ot2 movie cast you
want to go first
I think in the classroom setting it was
really good to have the
web-based I say we first started with
the download
the one where you can find the protocol
on open trons
change a couple of set parameters and
download a script and then feed that
script into the ot2 I think that was a
really good way to to get get some
confidence that you can run something on
this instrument
and it's visiting a website and sharing
some stuff
and sharing a script with the robot and
then the protocol designer gets more
into the design of the experiment
without having that programming
and then when people start running into
limitations of I want to do this or I
want to do that
that's when
you always have The Adventurous person
who wants to open that file with the
text editor and start messing with it
and I think
um
some people really love that challenge
and some others
I just want to get the protocol up and
running or modify and they can do it in
really creative ways with a GUI a
graphical user interface
yeah I mean
I I have probably have not much to add
to what you all just said
um
I I think it really ultimately depends
on the user right
um even if you have no programming
background at all uh you can operate ot2
because there's so much resource
available to you
um you know like you said there's I I
but if you don't have any programming
skill I I do highly recommend uh you
know either reaching out
to you know to open trons or to like a
reagent vendor like for instance zymo we
actually uh have the open transcripts
that we can provide but also like like I
said there's the protocol uh sort of
um
um database
that's a great place to start because at
least at that point you can find
something that's familiar to you and you
can kind of just seize through the map
and uh as you get more familiar with uh
python uh you can change things and
alter things to meet your particular
need
um but but they sort of Hit the kind of
extreme side that Collins was saying
like people who like to just mess with
the open trons like I know that there
are people who like 3D print sort of
like modules for the open drawings and
then they use a lot of python coding to
just to to make this system sort of take
you know custom to their particular need
and tailor it to their particular needs
so
um I think you just get the extremes uh
just because and I think it very much
demonstrates the versatility of the
system
yeah
thanks
because we have um one more minute left
I think we'll just do one final question
um so is there a reason why cell
transfers mammalian cell culture cells
are not emphasized in ot2 applications
um and I can I can take that but I'll
also ask
um uh
oh
uh and then there is one more comment
that I will make sure that we get to
after this as well but um uh I can
answer that question so uh I mean we do
do we do have some protocols uh around
um cell culture and and transfers and so
on it's not it's not a extremely it's
not one of our more popular applications
um obviously we do we do have a HEPA
filter but it's not you know the ot2 is
not naturally a uh uh contamination-free
environment you can add the HEPA filter
and so that helps
um but we do have some some protocols
around that so uh if you if if the
person who asked that wants to contact
us info opentrons.com
um we can see what we have uh that could
support you
and just we we we're out of time but I
wanted to say I wanted to read this that
just came in just a comment for Dr golla
first of all go wolf pack
yes biochemistry 2010 as an automation
scientist it's great to see automation
being included in Science Education lab
automation is a skill I picked up on the
job but it's becoming an increasingly
critical enabler of Biotech kudos for
giving your students the advantage of
exposure to this aspect of science
so I think that's a great a great way to
end but um thanks so much uh Grace for
that comment Carlos any any final words
oh yeah I think it goes back to that
don't fear the robot if we can get
people realizing that
the instrument may not do what you want
at first but you you can go back and
forth with it and and to learn really
cool tricks and then once once you have
a script that runs something it's really
fun
yeah I think that's the perfect
um I think we did have one more question
uh which we didn't get time to ask for
uh answer but if
um uh we can pick that up afterwards and
and answer via email but that's a great
note to end on so thank you so much
Carlos thanks so much Greg and thank you
so much everyone who joined uh and took
part
thank you